hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
from comic-con Superman coming to
Supergirl we finally got the first look
but that's not even the end of it we
have news about the four night crossover
and maybe Superboy coming to the show
too so the biggest thing first like
Superman is a really big deal but you
guys probably want to know more about
the four night crossover they did say
you know just because of the order in
which the shows happened during the week
organizationally it made sense for the
big crisis that's going to be happening
to start with Supergirl she'll be the
primary character to jump from a show to
show to carry the story forward through
the week so even though they haven't
revealed what the big crisis is going to
be that's going to necessitate a four
and I crossover like why all these
heroes have to work together clearly
something really big is going to happen
but because legends of tomorrow is such
a big time travel show and they'll
probably use that fourth night to fix
whatever big crazy thing has happened
I'm guessing there's gonna be a
time-travel component all out
reverse-flash
it'll also involve the multiverse but
Marc Guggenheim actually said I don't
want to oversell it Supergirl is going
to be jumping from show to show but I
don't want to oversell it so when he
says that he's basically saying like
we're not doing an T monitor we're not
gonna do like a carbon copy of crisis on
Infinite Earths or anything like that
and you have to remember they kind of
already did a moment like that in the
flash season two finale so just careful
for spoilers from that so at the end of
the comic book crisis on Infinite Earths
during the mid-80s Barry Allen
sacrificed himself to save the earth
from this big antimatter gun that the
anti-monitor was gonna use to destroy it
so the flash TV show basically used that
moment because zoom was doing a very
crisis on Infinite Earths type thing
where he was going to destroy the
multiverse
if Barry didn't destroy his big device
so they've kind of already used the
conceit for crisis on Infinite Earths
but I know you're all wondering if
they're going to use this to merge
supergirls earth with earth one they've
been very vague about which earth she's
on and whether or not they want to
permanently merge the characters from
her show like her earth with earth one
from arrow and flash so just remains to
be seen but it would be awesome to see
her on the same earth with arrow and
flash even if they don't end up skyping
each other every single episode after
that you just you create a couple story
problems when you bring Superman onto
your earth
because like Cisco and Felicity for
instance if Superman existed on our
earth that would be all that Cisco and
Felicity talked about so just remains to
be seen about what Supergirl status is
relative to earth one after the big
crossover but what I'm expecting is is
it'll be the same episode it is every
year it'll be Episode eight of each show
now Supergirl is starting like a week
later than arrow in flash so would be
like Episode seven of Supergirl
but for the most part it'll probably air
the same time and airs every year and
the really important thing this isn't
really an arrow video so I'm not gonna
comment about this too much but the big
crossover episode eight of arrow this
year is this 100th episode so just
expect some extra fanservice on top of
all this big crossover fanservice stuff
usually they save the really fun
fanservice stuff for the big gimmicky
episodes like this so will it be fun but
Superman on Supergirl so this is a huge
deal
if you're wondering why there hasn't
been footage or a trailer yet it's
because they just started filming with
the character like all these pictures
you've been saying this is from this
past week which is the week after Comic
Con so naturally they didn't really have
any footage to show off before so when
they actually did their Comic Con panel
last weekend Tyler hoechlin was like
well I haven't even worn the costume yet
but this is what he looks like as Clark
Kent this is what he looks like as
Superman so expect that first trailer
they'll definitely put Superman in it
but expect that in the next couple of
weeks
the Superman has only been confirmed for
the first couple of episodes then he'll
come back later he'll be butting heads
with car-like he has his own idea for
how justice should be served Cara has a
slightly different opinion of that so
they'll be butting heads the characters
will be a little bit different so Kat
grant is pretty much not coming back
like she'll guest star every once in a
while but they're basically swapping her
out with this character here he'll be
like the day-to-day Perry White figure
so I'm really happy about that and
they've revealed who is in the capsule
at the end of season 1 so another
Kryptonian capsule that looks just like
Cara's lands on earth at the end of the
season finale but they don't reveal
who's in it this is the person that's in
it so what I think they might be doing
is they're bringing another Kryptonian
to earth and it'll be like Mon L if you
don't know who Mon L is he's basically a
version of Superboy so I think they're
bringing Superboy on to the TV show but
it's going to be the Mon L version of
the character so most of you are
probably familiar with the Conner Kent
Superboy
he was a hybrid of Superman and
that was cloned by STAR Labs so the
difference with the Mon L character is
is that his actual real name is larg and
he's from a different planet that's
called Dax emits like a Kryptonian
colony but they're descended from
Kryptonians so effectively he has all
the same powers that Superman and
Supergirl would have so functionally
what it seemed like they had always
intended to do was bring Superboy on the
show but it would be the monell version
of the character so I'm actually really
excited about the idea of Superboy on
Supergirl
so you guys let me know in the comments
we all know what's going on with
Superman he's gonna be a lot of fun but
just because this character here looks
like he could totally be Superman let me
know do you think that they are doing
Superboy so there's a whole bunch more
comic-book stuff happening I'm gonna be
doing Black Panther later tonight but
there is a new round of the DC giveaway
that starts now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'm expecting a
couple more big trailers for all the
shows in the next week or two I know I
haven't done agents of shield yet
there's Ghost Rider stuff happening on
agents of shield so we got some black
panther coming up the Teen Choice Awards
are tonight there might be some new
footage that drops from some stuff so if
there is I'll totally do a video for
that too
so bunch of cool stuff coming later
tonight so while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn all about the final season the
game of Thrones and the spin-off that
they're working on and you can click
here to learn all about the flashpoint
timeline during the flash season 3 thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tide